ça marche one two three
bonsoir
la plupart d'entre vous ou certains
d'entre vous connaissent mon nom
mountaga qui est un produit de la guinée
d'abord avant de d'aller ailleurs
j'ai grandi tout juste à côté de conakry
vives dont le passé la banlieue la
banlieue c'était ici à colère aller vers
dixinn le côté c'était trop loin c'était
la haute banlieue c'était comme aller à
courrier aujourd'hui
donc en montant je venais à l'école ici
ça s'appelait la place des martyrs il y
avait des feux rouges je me rappelle que
je m'asseyais tout le temps en attendant
qu'on vienne me chercher à l'école sous
le feux rouges et j'attendais presque à
quelques centimes et du goudron je jure
garder ce feu le côté qui tournait rouge
jaune vert dans toutes les couleurs et
j'étais fasciné
ensuite je voyais les avions aussi volé
je me disais c'est fascinant tout ça
sans
1981-1982 donc quelques certains étaient
là en sept ans donc voilà j'ai regardé
toutes ces technologies ch'ti fascinant
la guinée était fermé c'était la corée
du nord tout ce qu'on pouvait avoir
quelques véhicules vous pouviez rouler
d'ici à peu près jusqu'à la minière en
15 minutes après ça s'est remplie bien
sûr on sait aujourd'hui comment est ce
qui se passe de lacaune à gré mais je
regardais cette technologie les avions
qui venait ut à ça n'existait plus r-
afrique
aeroflot d'ailleurs quand cet avion
l'arrivée tout conakry tremblay quoi ce
qu'elle a
donc je me suis dit moi aussi moi je
vais commencer à faire quelque chose en
vue alors avec les petits amis là les
petits gamins quartier en jeu tous
ensemble avant y'avait pas de
discrimination tous les gamins jouent
ensemble
ont fabriqué les p'tites boutures ont
prenez par exemple ou tort moi j'adorais
faire pas même les volvo et les mercedes
d'autres mfr les camions les plus agiles
faisait des camions super solide on
prenait nos grillage désolé papas ont
coupé le grillage on mettait dans les
antennes de radio l'aller c'est une
radio on mettait pour bien plié pour
avoir la forme d'un côté le côté faisait
passer les traverses ont démonté les
vieux fils téléphoniques parce qu'il y
avait plusieurs couleurs à l'intérieur
on enroule est là dessus on rend des
sabots sexy la torche de la grand mère
ou de la moment on casse et s'en
prennent et lampes où l'on mettait
devant les piles les anciennes pile avec
rouge là avec les petits châle noir le
vous rappeler ça dure même pas 20
minutes la pile on utilisait sa et la
nuit on était content de petites
voitures là ça roule et les femmes
j'adorerais cette époque le fait que la
guinée y ait des pénuries de jouer en ce
moment il n'avait pas de made in china
la chine était aussi pauvre que non
donc il fallait inventer ces jouets on
inventé nous jouer et on adorait ça on
gardait ses yeux pendant des mois et des
mois aujourd'hui lorsque j'achète des
jouets pour monfils c'est une question
d'une semaine s'est cassé même quelques
jours s'est cassée les technologies
indigènes les technologies locales à
nous naissent aussi avec nous c'est pas
ailleurs qu'au 9 ça vient de nous mêmes
à l'âge de 3 ans à l'âge de 4 ans à
l'âge de 5 ans nous commencerons imagin
ait mal moi aussi j'ai envie de faire ça
sans même copié quelquefois nous
imaginons la première fois que j'ai
touché à l'électricité on me disait le
courant est dedans ne touche pas alors
j'ai pris un brin de balle et les sacs
at il il pleuvait prix les bruns je
regardais gauche droite et avait
personne j'avais 5 ans et j'ai mis à
l'intérieur et là j'ai décollé comme une
fusée j'ai atterri
j'ai compris c'était quoi court
peut-être céder 300 vols comme encore
mais je fuis mais y compris donc j'ai
toujours été curieux le jeune le petit
qu'elle a est toujours curieux nous
enfonçons curieux lorsqu'il voit la
bouille veulent sauter dedans pouvoir
les faits c'est la curiosité il faut les
encourager
quelques années après
1987 je me rappelle avec mon père dans
sa nivat qui est toute nouvelle année va
en fait c'est comme une charrette qui
est un moteur c'est ça ne vas tu n'y a
pas de direction assistée un soviétique
c'est rude
et on était dedans et je les dis
papa c'est quoi un jour là je vais faire
décoller la fusée guinée galon il te
laisseront jamais faire tu pourras
jamais le faire on va jamais autorisé
l'extérieur ne va jamais accepter j'ai
dit mais pourquoi pourquoi ils ont droit
d'inventer et nous on n'a pas droit
d'inventer chez bernard fau même pas
touché alors j'ai commencé à me
passionner aux fusées et autres et où
j'allais aussi à la bibliothèque franco
guinéenne qui était là à côté du coup
bang j'allais là-bas je passé toute la
journée à regarder les neil armstrong
youri gagarine g touré s'était pas peur
je sais tout même leurs moteurs fusées
des radios gage connait tous la z ça m'a
servi à quoi à rien pourquoi parce qu'on
a simplement dit bon tu ne peux pas sois
avocat pour la famille enfin sur la
docteure pour la faune donc nos familles
nous oriente
donc j'ai fini par faire des études de
droit en france voilà ensuite plus tard
des études autre chose aux états unis
international business ensuite bon en
gros je m'appelle donc mountaga keita je
suis ex juriste en france je suis
ex-banquier aux états unis directeur de
banque je suis rentré en guinée je me
suis cherché et maintenant je suis
bricoleur
je suis le pdg de tulipes industrie qui
est basé ici en guinée nous fabriquons
des technologies utiles aux pays en
développement et bizarrement des pays
très développés sont en train de
solliciter nos technologies
mais le sujet d'aujourd'hui c'est la
difficile confiance dont nous
technologie indigènes les technologies
locales faudrait d'abord que je définis
certains petits monts parce que sinon
certains risquent de penser que je
parlais des technologies aborigènes ont
jeudi indigènes indigènes veut tout
simplement dire le calme en fait une
technologie fait aux états unis peut
être appeler une technologie indigènes à
l'amérique une française technologie
indigènes à la france point final donc
on utilise je n'utiliserai pas ce mot et
jane ici dans un sens négatif plutôt
dire locale la technologie seco aussi
tech leurs gosses technique l'étude du
savoir-faire comment faire le suse logos
et les hélicos à l'étude comment faire
ça voilà la technique aussi est propre à
l'afrique
l'afrique a toujours su créer inventer
avant l' esclavage on invente un créé le
faire on le maîtrise des techniques
telles que par exemple en egypte ou en
opérer de la cataracte dans l'ancienne
egypte alors quand il repense ça
n'existait même pas en asie peut-être
appel mais en afrique ça se faisait la
maîtrise aussi des constellations par
exemple c'est à dire les dessins formé
par des étoiles pour s'orienter
il ya une étoile qui s'appelait sirius
par exemple l'étude de sirius a été
faite par le peuple dogon depuis deux à
trois mille ans et ça c'est au mali sont
des peuples normalement si vous voyez
vous allez descendre peuples primitifs
une sévère et de grands une connaissance
tellement extrême que la nasa s'est
récemment que la nasa a pu découvrir
certaines choses et confirmer ce que les
deux candidats est depuis deux trois
mille ans c'était là mais voilà ce qui
s'est passé il ya eu une cassure
dans le mot dans la phrase la difficile
confiance ya le mot confiance
qu'on
la cepal insultant qu'on veut dire avec
en espagne un handicap et à cannes elle
veut dire avec fiance ce vient de
fédérer la fois avoir la foi avec
quelqu'un
on avait confiance en nous même en créer
l avant l' esclavage
l'esclavagé venu détruire beaucoup de
choses énormément de choses il nous
faudra peut-être plusieurs années ou une
bonne centaine d'années avant de refaire
certaines choses comme avant ou voir
même heure certaines choses se sont
ancrés en nous dans notre adn à force de
répéter une chose la chose finit par
s'inscrire comme un code informatique
dans le sens dans l'adn et on passe
aussi certaines choses sans comprendre
sans savoir même culturellement à nos
enfants et c'est ce qui est arrivé avec
l'escale esclavage et la colonisation
il ya une étude récente de harvard par
exemple qui prouve avec des algorithmes
que des peuples qui ont été affectés
plus les plus par l'esclavagé son époque
où la confiance est moindre donc son
d'époque ensuite même qu'ils se sont
retrouvés à très vite prendre des amis
des parents et à les vendre en esclavage
saviez comment certains faisait il
appelé leurs amis qui n'aimait pas là il
disait aide-moi la toutoute le jeune ami
sur le bateau des pauses masala et puis
revient une fois sur le bateau utilisé
je la vends où je le vend c'est comme ça
il faisait donc avec l' esclavage s'est
inscrit dans notre adn de ne pas avoir
confiance en l'autre qu'il y a des peu
faut pas trop le faire confiance parce
qu'ils pourraient de vendre vendre une
princesse une reine un roi il ya des
rois qui a été vendue par exemple donc
cette manque de confiance est ancré en
nous à la fin et la vni finit par
s'inscrire presque dans l'adn donc il
faut du temps pour enlever ça donc on a
du mal à faire confiance les uns envers
les autres un exemple aux états unis le
studio rockefeller lorsqu'il a commencé
avec quelques saints tu vas y avait
personne pour comparer avec autre chose
donc lui lorsqu'il a créé n'était pas
dans l'esclavagé n'est rien valjean eu
confiance qui sont partisans adopté sa
technologie henry ford la même chose il
ya aussi cet élément de comparaison
nous ne faisons pas confiance dans nos
technologies ordinaire locale ça c'est
sûr et certain
tulipe industry's est une société qui
est née depuis 2014 dans la discrétion
tulipe industries a fait des recherches
et développement de 2014 à 2017 dans
toute la discrétion sans publicité ni
rien en 2017 on a affiché on a gagné le
concours de l'entrepreneur c'était beau
mais ensuite le cauchemar a commencé
je croyais pertinemment que en
fabriquant une technologie utile pour
l'éducation pour la santé je crois que
ouais ça allait marcher sa démarche et
l'afrique soit 1.3 milliard mois au
niveau technique c'est super mais au
niveau confiance 0 tout le monde te tape
pas sur le banc assez bien tout le monde
enverra un look digne et watts à baho
c'est super j'adore sa part que linkedin
what's up si vous m'envoyez continuer
mais le problème c'est qu'on a besoin de
contrat sinon on peut pas vivre on peut
pas vivre ça coûte de l'argent moi j'ai
dû vendre ma famille a dû vendre une
maison jeudi vent dans un véhicule j'ai
dû finir tout mais c'est ring comme les
économies aux etats-unis jeudi claqué la
porte la balle où est ma maison là bas
pour pouvoir subvenir 1 que aux besoins
de l'entreprise mais ces technologies
sont là alors une fois et j'ai eu une
idée plutôt la jeune soeur a eu une idée
elle m'a dit écoute en afrique ans fait
pas confiance je dis malheureusement
c'est inconsciente elle dit bon écoute
essayer d'aller à l'étranger si tu pars
à l'étranger tu gagne là bas tu vas voir
directement ils vont être gardés mais
non faut pas faire ça faudrait pas quand
même que ce soit validé par l'étranger
alors que moi je suis rentré pour bosser
là lé fais ce que je te dis et tu verras
j'ai commencé les concours bab africa au
maroc ensuite kigali directement m'a
détecté l'une des 5 ampères l'innovation
en afrique en 2018 ensuite le bénin a
reçu une médaille d'or de genève de
l'organisation internationale la
propriété intellectuelle sur 60
inventeur qui avaient leurs brevets je
finis par avoir la médaille d'or par
rapport à 60 invention brevetée en
afrique c'est la dignité cette médaille
alors merci la médaille d'or et les
grosses magnifique elle est chez moi et
ma femme ils adorent mais elle ne
nourrit pas
vous comprenez alors ensuite elle m'a
dit continue est sur une bonne lancée
l'oapi m'a désigné pour les représenter
l'afrique 17 pays à genève
800 exposants plus de 30000 visiteurs
c'est la mecque c'est la totale c'est ce
qu'on dit en amérique et en anglais
américain bb bring it on était là
vailhès nous j'avais que deux mètres
imoca de deux mètres sur 2 mètres la
chine là bas avait presque 500 m²
d'exposition
l'arabie saoudite de leur côté avaient
au moins vu ses quatre moteurs fallait
voir les surfaces taiwan rivaliser avec
la chine pour avoir la plus grande
surface d'exposition possible j'avais
comme anti de mature de même avec le
rouge le jaune et le vert croyez-moi
salon de genève médaille d'or
[Applaudissements]
yes week-end comme obama l'a dit on peut
le faire en se moquant entre nous mais
vous ne savez pas à l'extérieur ce que
ça fait non seulement la médaille d'or
du salon de genève avec un diplôme qui
dit avec les félicitations du jury ça
c'était à genève sur 800 exposition
pauvreté
j'ai ramené cette médaille d'or ici
comprenez ça marche ensuite dans ce même
salon la délégation française la
délégation des inventeurs de faussement
décerné aussi leur médaille d'or
ensuite il a eu la délégation des
inventeurs de repas que le président des
inventeurs d'europe de l'association qui
me décerne aussi le diplôme léonard de
vinci des inventeurs de repos
bardé de tout ça je suis revenu au pays
et la maintenance a commencé à exploser
elle m'a dit tu vois ce que je t'ai dit
la difficile confiance dans le
technology indigènes donc comme je vous
ai expliqué tout à l'heure ça vient un
peu c'est un peu ancré en nous dans
notre adn ça vient un peu de loin on
avait une confiance dans le passé ça a
été cassée la parenthèse est fermé
est-ce que la vache colonisation c'est
fini et aujourd'hui nous assistons à une
sorte de renaissance savez vous que
depuis 2010 7e explosions phénoménales
des start up en afrique l'afrique compte
aujourd'hui 1 point 3 milliards
1.3 milliard d'habitants dans cinq ans
non plutôt dans nos rangs c'est à dire
en 2030 autour 2030 2035 savez vous que
35 à 40 % de la population africaine
aura atteint un niveau de vie moyen ou
élevé oui on a atteint un niveau de vie
on peut dire qui peut concurrencer voire
même supérieure au niveau de vie
américain ou français un exemple je suis
banquier j'étais banquier on avait des
statistiques dans les banques qui disait
très simplement si vous êtes américains
vous avez 20 dollar en poche aucune des
tas de mais aucune des deux voitures
aucune des deux écoles vous faites
partie des 10 % d'américains les plus
riches 20 $
en guinée la plupart d'entre vous ou vos
parents détiennent leur maison ils sont
le titre foncier cae ya aucune dette
lorsque vous avez une voiture c'est à
vous de ce que vous avez une maison
c'est à vous et vous savez ça vaut
combien une maison aujourd'hui à conakry
plusieurs milliards il ya des maisons
qui se vendent ici des terrains nus à un
million d'euros verlan by on est assis
sur de l'argent comprend même pas on se
fait pas confiance alors que les gens
vont commencer maintenant à innover et à
prendre conscience que l on vient de
rendre personnellement ce fait harvard
il y en a deux qui ont fait hier nous
avons deux turbines et au canada qui est
un docteur en intelligence artificielle
qui veut rentrer mais les opportunités
sens où on adaptera brûle kaba piège d
intelligence artificielle il est à
l'endive est rentré c'est où alors moi
j'ai décidé de me sacrifie tulipes
industrie a décidé de le faire revenir
nous comptons sur eux mais ne compte
aussi sur les autorités qui sont là les
entreprises qui sont là de nous faire
confiance de faire confiance à ces
technologies locales
il faut le faire parce que l'ase les caf
vient de s'ouvrir la zone de
libre-échange de l'afrique voilà tous
les pays sont presque dedans produits en
guinée tu pourras à vendre en afrique du
sud en ce moment les importations je
peux pas vous dire combien de milliards
parce que les chiffres mêmes se
contredisent peut-être 400 milliards de
dollars par an on perd des centaines de
milliards certains mêmes parlent de
trillions de dollars qu'on perdra en ne
serait-ce que 20% de ces marchés là si
on produisait localement on pourrait
résoudre déjà presque à peu près 100 %
de chômage
seul je m'ennuie à la maison j'ai
commencé à inventer j'ai créé une
entreprise seuls des finances à fond de
profond familie même pas de banque
aujourd'hui nous sommes 74 employés à
tulle et d'industrie seul si j'ai pu le
faire seule vous imaginez combien
d'autres stars tupper pourront le faire
il y aura des stats peur ici demain
ces start peur faites leur confiance et
la confiance c'est quoi c'est pas en
tapotant sur le pôle en envoyant un
petit sms rapide non non non donnez leur
un contrat même si 5000 de la sagesse
qui va en faire milles de là elle va
faire le petit boulot d'accord mais la
confiance y pourra dire j'ai collaboré
avec le tenue j'ai collaboré avec la
banque mondiale et collabore même si ces
500 dollars même si ces 5 millions de
francs guinéens millions de francs
guinéens tant pis mais au moins vous
aurez montrer que vous leur faites
confiance c'est pas sur le menton c'est
plutôt sur l'aura voilà
montant infini je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]